[Music]
so
[Music]
so
welcome to the finale of cyber up your
pc a contest where we asked our
community members to create the raddest
custom cyberpunk 2077 themed builds
during the first stage of the contest we
received over 1700 entries
and selected five designs whose authors
later on were teamed up with five
professional modding teams
their task was to bring those designs to
life and to share them with everyone
during the finale we're having today
these five amazing designs will be
fighting for the main prize
an alienware aurora pc with a limited
nvidia g4
cyberpunk 2077 edition along with other
awesome gaming peripherals
brought to you by our partners alienware
nvidia
and steelseries cyber up your pc is a
unique pc modding contest during which
we'd like to draw special attention to
one of the most precious resources we
have
so devastated in the cyberpunk universe
our environment
that's why all of the entries will also
be rated based on the number of recycled
materials used in each build
on top of that a copy of the winning
design will be put on charity auction
with the winner of the finale picking
which foundation receives the donation
now it's time to rate the top 5
submissions and pick the winner together
with our partners
pavel could not share his video with us
however he sent
over his ratings along with the notes
which i will proceed to read along with
other judges
[Music]
my name is angus jones i'm from perth
western australia
i'm a massive cyberpunk enthusiast and
the designer for the pc
case mod fonder's throne hi my name is
tim timberley manboy
and i'm a custom pc designer and case
model from sweden
i've been doing this for quite a while
now building
for competitions exhibitions like
computex
dreamac and so on it was a heavy
research component which involved me
understanding the cyberpunk 2077 world
the upholstery design for bondi's throne
features a
custom voodoo voice pattern which was
originally inspired from the gang's logo
the cyber terminals that were shown
during the original gameplay footage
videos
became a key feature that i wanted to
have when i was doing my early designs i
was incorporating
a lot of recycled materials into the pc
case mod
however when i took a step back i saw
bondi's phone as a way
to have the entire piece be a recycled
concept
so this was definitely the most creative
of the bunch turning an actual chair
into a
full computer setup we were super
impressed with the work done on this
throne
it's amazing to see such an ambitious
concept art be brought to life
it's absolutely a voodoo boys inspired
netrunner's chair
no doubt about it the attention to
detail was very evident
both in terms of recreating a pc
in the chair form factor as well as
borrowing elements from the game in
order to bring
bandai's cheer to life and overall the
chair does kind of give the appearance
of looking like something you would find
in the cyberpunk universe
it's obvious that he spent a lot of time
fabricating it i also like that it was
themed after a specific faction that
hasn't gotten a lot of love this mod
used a fair amount of pc parts
starting from reducing an old framework
into various components such as foot and
armrest all the way to recycling old
laptops as decoration
9 out of 10 points bandai's chair
received a final score of 9.4
bandai's throne gets eight points from
us i give bandai's throne and eight out
of ten
bandai's throne received a total of
eight points from pavel
bondi's throw and i'm going to give
third from my ranking at eight points
out of ten
hello my name is 31 years old
i live in bangkok thailand i am a
feeling
photographer and classic designer hi my
name is niklas and i'm the moderator and
owner at forsberg customs
i put all the love i have for the craft
into my work and i hope it shows
enjoy the installation for that design i
choose to use
militech gang by looking at the
characters
fashion the way her clothes drive the
weapons they use so i choose to use
black color as the main area i think
to use carbon fiber surfaces in
cyclomatic
the next one is called the neo black and
this one
is basically a it looks like a full
blackout design
this mod definitely has the cyberpunk
slash sci-fi genre aesthetic
it looks like it could be a maelstrom
creation for sure it looks like it has a
carbon fiber maybe vinyl or
wrap on the top or if it's if it's real
fiberglass work or something
that's extra impressive i love the
artist's interpretation
of bringing this contrast of cutting
edge
and reclaimed old and new it's a very
solid job
he really liked the reclaimed parts
around the outside of the case
and the use of carbon fiber that kind of
gave it that
military feel to it i just had a wish it
had a little bit more wow factor
this mod uses a lot of old pc parts two
motherboards
nine defective memory sticks and two old
drives it feels like nearly the entirety
of the mod has been done using these
very nice nine out of ten the neo black
concept received a final score
of 7.1 we gave neil black six points
i give the neon the neo black a five out
of ten
neo black received a total of five
points from pavel the neo black i'm
gonna rank
at six
hi my name is kasper and i'm an aspiring
concept artist
i'm 26 years old and i'm from poland
after school i was hired by a company
called puppets war
we are designing and manufacturing
tabletop miniatures
and collectibles for hobbyists around
the world
hi i'm valentine i'm tom i'm carl
and we are micromods we've been building
pc mods since 2015
and we're close team of international
creators based in norway
there was a key phrase in the rules that
goes in the night city
the rich and the poor live right next to
each other
make this contrast visible in your
design so basic idea
was to take military high tech stuff and
combine it with some mad max style
solutions
to display that contrast so the whole
process of designing i started with
extensive research of everything that
has been shown on cyberpunk 2077
until that point then i moved to
sketching in 2d to
explore the ideas around the story when
i had a concept that i was happy with i
took some time and learned a 3d software
to make the forms there after that i did
a simple paint over in photoshop
i aimed for realistic depiction always
thinking how it's going to be built
later after i was selected to the top
five the marker mods did their magic
and made this project a reality the
artist had a very thoughtful approach
to what he wanted to do in order to
bring cyberpunk
story to life i love how worn it looks
it really looks like it could have come
straight out of the game it definitely
looks like a military
device the case mod they've done it
nicely mixes a clean corporate style
with gang mods
finders keepers is a very nice mix of a
kang tile design with an
entropism inspired diy style overlay
the whole aesthetic works with each
other from all the weathering on the
reclaimed computer parts all around it
it's got sort of legs out to the side of
it almost like it's a turret or like a
spider bot or something
the use of metal rods and grit that
would otherwise rust on a dump somewhere
make this mod really stand out
we can also see very nice example of
recycling old electronics such as the
old network switch
8 out of 10 here binders keepers concept
received a final score
of 8.4 it was an amazing build and we
gave it
nine points i give finders keepers a six
out of ten
finders keepers received a total of
seven points from pavo finders keepers
six
hi my name is i'm
37 years old and i have lived in madrid
for the last 8 years
working in an art studio as a digital
scooper
hi i'm simone marino aka the cave from
the italian extreme mother's team
and before showing you the project let
me introduce you the rest of the team
stefano charpeletti aka samod franco
martinelli
aka warboy umberto todaro aka
todd mod fabio perkiatzi aka tech4gaming
and massimiliano paris otto aka arbor
numbers
we are a few fans of akira and when we
saw the bike in the pacific
gameplay we fell in love with the design
kusanagi has some elements which are
quite interesting to apply into the
alingwari aura
since the beginning we wanted to design
to be something that we wanted to have
in our best
something that we were willing to throw
more uh
that i would like to highlight are the
stickers
we were we made them with behind by
absolutely um
we have included a lot of easter eggs
replacing the small text of several of
them this is the entry that reflects
cyberpunk style over substance nature
the most
i absolutely love this one this one was
definitely my favorite
really reminds me of kind of that akira
vibe we love the bright colors
and body panels that attach to the sides
of it that gave it that sort of
cyber street bike feel the damage to the
paneling
is really well done it looks like it's
maybe taking a few slides on the ground
the red color that they chose is so
different from any of the others
it just really really pops very good
build quality
all elements match up nicely the paint
job is neat
and stickers look great too this is a
great
reinterpretation and a great effort
to bring this motorcycle from the game
to life here we can see a very nice use
of parts from all vehicles
although those were the only recycled
elements used it's worth noting that the
3d printed elements have been created
using biodegradable filament
7 out of 10 points here the yaiba
kusunagi aura concept received a final
score
of 9.1 we gave yaiba seven points
uh definitely my favorite amazing job
guys i give this one
a nine out of 10. yayiba kusanagi
received a total of 9 points from pavero
we're going to go with 10 on that as
well
hi my name is matin a few words about me
i'm originally from tehran iran
and i'm a visual effects artist here in
germany and i think it goes without
saying that i'm a huge cyberpunk fan
hello my name is sasha tveterak i'm a
professional modder and
maker of props and stenography for
movies okay so for my design i was
heavily inspired by the militech
flathead robot
seen in the 2018 gameplay demo so the
way i approach this design i knew right
off the bat
i want to have this cold steel corporate
style of the miltec
corporation and also this aggressive
look of the
maelstrom gang starting from the
military aspect i added
thick pieces of metal that would go with
big pipes hard edges
metal a lot of steel and for the
maelstrom design aesthetic
i imagine some psycho board got their
hands on it and tried to make it their
own
so they added the skulls these crazy
writings these crazy
gang signs as well to show that it
belongs to them now and so my ultimate
goal was to make this design look really
mean
and aggressive this mod instantly brings
cyberpunk 2077's spiderbot design to
mind
it has a grim dystopian cyberpunk look
to it inspired by the psycho ganks of
the dark future
great build quality legs and original
corporate metal parts are sharp and
clean
really impressive and good work this is
the type of exactly the type of thing
i would expect to find at a trade show
like a major trade show for the industry
uh this is so far beyond what i was
expecting
and it's amazing uh the legs moving is
just next level it was hard enough to
build a pc mod but then to also make
moving legs is just absolutely next
level and
honestly kind of terrifying you could
just tell that they spent a lot of time
and
thought in it from the design all the
way to actually
bringing it to life what i love about it
is
this creative and very careful
combination
of what such as corporation the
industrial feel
and this element of game aside from the
typical parts like an old motherboard or
cords from a console controller
you can find parts from things like
rollerblades industrial heaters
microwave or an old radio it even uses
old guitar
strings the spirit of the contest has
been captured here perfectly
10 out of 10. the militech curves had
bought
received a final score of 7.4 beautiful
craftsmanship
miltek bot gets 9 points from us i give
the maelstrom mod a 7 out of 10.
militechbot received a total of 8.5
points from pavo and i'm going to give
the curve headbot
10 points out of 10.
and there you have it it was an insanely
close battle between the finalists but
the
ultimate winners leading by less than
one point are martin and stasik tibbs
vertelac
congratulations guys and the winner is
the militech bot maestro mod by star
and matthew nice really nice
i don't know what to say to be healthy
like it was it was really crazy because
we when i saw the design i was like it's
hard
to move it wouldn't be complete without
moving legs
well first of all i would say all the
credit or i mean all the credits should
go to uh
static if i pronounce his name correctly
we haven't actually talked
okay yeah all the credit should go to
him
because this is like art on another
level
the execution was done so perfectly i
couldn't believe that it was like the
real case
thank you to starjek for this great
execution i also think
thank you guys i it's awesome
thank you thank you once again
congratulations to the winners
and to the finalists all five mods were
amazing and it was
very difficult to pick just one design
as you can see by the scores
it's time to select a charity martin who
should receive the donation from the
auction
all right so for my choice of charity
i'm going with the best friends item of
society
because their mission is to provide a
comfortable life even for the animals
that don't get adopted
i mean i have a pet myself i recommend
anyone who can afford to get a pet
to just go and get a pet but sadly there
aren't enough people out there that can
do that
so i still prefer for these animals to
not get killed at these shelters and
have a comfortable life
that's why i'm choosing the best friends
animal society
and now as a bonus we have some exciting
news to share with all the pc gamers out
there waiting for official
cyberpunk 2077 system requirements
without further ado
here's what you will need to enjoy the
game
thank you to all the participants who
submitted their designs thank you to our
partners who helped us organize this
contest
and thank you all for tuning in see you
in night city on november 19th
you